foreign
cancellation I must again unfortunately
cancel people on my own side or at least
theoretically on my own side um these
are the conservatives who over the past
few days have been frantically
applauding their latest hero their newly
elected spokesman their trendiest new
conservative Champion Jeffrey Starr and
for those unfamiliar as I was until two
days ago star is a social media
influencer and owner of a popular I
think Cosmetics brand uh star also
enjoys dressing like a woman
but this flamboyant cross-dressing
makeup salesman earned Applause from any
on the right including prominent figures
on the right
when he appeared on a podcast and said
this
I might even tell all the other I think
what other Vive in them yeah and all
that extra that we added during the
pandemics everyone was so bored on their
houses they just started to make up more
more stuff yeah that's where the
conservatives like me because I'm just
real yeah you do have a conservative to
them you're trans your male or your
female
and you're standing on that so mad when
I say that how are you with they what
the does that mean as stupid as
what it is yeah but you need someone
like me that looks like me to say it
because if you say it it turns into your
homophobic you hate trans people you
hate gays and it's just how you feel you
don't hate anyone you just think it's
stupid
now that what you just heard makes
Jeffree Star based apparently he's based
now he said one thing that conservatives
like and they were on the scene with
pom-poms in no time and yes star is
right that the they them stuff is BS of
course
obviously but the problem one of them
anyway is that he rejects non-binary
while affirming trans he says that the
only valid categories are trans male or
female
and to drive that point home he made
another video responding to the backlash
against his anti-the- them commentary
where he reiterated his support for and
belief in transgenderism here it is
I just went on and I saw a few Outlets
saying that I'm transphobic Jeffree Star
who has five transgender employees
I have over 100 employees of all
different ethnicities
a brand that is inclusive to the entire
world what we're not going to do is lie
so if you posted an article saying
anything like that you better delete it
Miss thing because I'm coming
all I said was I don't agree with
pronouns that's it
so you know how cardi B sued that woman
and Well the lady don't have any money
but cardi B1 allegedly a lot of money
from the lawsuit even though she'll
never get it it's still the point of she
won that was phenomenal for someone like
me that has been abused and dragged
through the mud now we all know all my
past mistakes girl every time that I
have an opinion ever has to bring up
everything from the past
it's that's getting so old but the
support and the understanding and the
common sense for millions of people that
I've seen over the last few days it made
it made me realize I'm the planet's not
that awful like people get it it's just
social media and they love to drag Miss
Jeffrey Lynn
also shout out to so many amazing
beautiful transgender people and the
LGBT community and my DMs writing me
um just thank you
this is I'm sorry about that this is
just too much between between this guy
and the uh Gloria Johnson tweet it's
just
the amount of brain cells we're losing
it's really it's like the effect of a of
a concussion we're all now concussed
effectively because of the level of
stupidity that we've been been forced
well that I have forced you to
encounter today
um but very inspiring response from this
right-wing Warrior who desperately
defends himself from the transphobia
claims by bragging about all the trans
people he employs
I suppose it just goes to show that
Democrats really are the real
transphobes of course check back in
about five years and people on the right
will be defending transgenderism and
non-binary but then claiming that uh
trans speciesism is where they draw the
line and somehow that position will be
applauded as not only correct but but
based
so this is how it works as the Overton
window continues its Relentless March to
the left what was a fringe left-wing
view yesterday suddenly becomes
mainstream today and The Fringe today
will be mainstream tomorrow
meanwhile the oblivious faction of
conservatives a rather large group
unfortunately continue to embrace any
position that is not at this moment on
the extreme left-wing Fringe
as long as it's not the most extreme
version of leftism they embrace it
which means that tomorrow they will
Embrace whatever is on the extreme
left-wing Fringe today
Jeffree star's conservative Defenders
have told me that well we should accept
him into the fold because he is they say
mostly right about the gender issue
but he's not mostly right he's not even
in a neighborhood of right
he's he's not in the play he's not I
don't know what planet he's even on let
alone the neighborhood
he believes that a person can identify
as and actually be a member of the
opposite sex he affirms China
transgenderism it's just that he prefers
to stick with the term transgender to
describe those people and believes that
non-binary is extra and redundant
and he's right that it is redundant you
know as non-binary versus transgenderism
that is a distinction without a
difference so that doesn't make him more
right or closer to the truth he's not
suddenly a Defender Of Truth and
tradition because he prefers to stick
with the craziest left-wing ideas from
yesterday rather than adopting the
craziest ideas from today
in fact non-binary isn't even really
crazier than transgenderism these terms
are again redundant they are versions of
the same nonsense
star prefers using one term for the
nonsense rather than two this apparently
is enough to make him Our Generations
William F Buckley
the left here is using a classic
manipulation technique you make an
outrageous demand so that a slightly
less outrageous demand seems reasonable
by comparison we should all be familiar
with the strategy it's the oldest one in
the book right kids use it all the time
just a few nights ago my son
came up to me after dinner and said
Daddy can we all go get ice cream
now asking me to load all six kids in
the car after dinner
when I already have my sweatpants and
slippers on definitely qualifies as an
outrageous demand that's one thing they
know
once the slippers come out I'm not going
anywhere that we're we are here for the
night
so I said no and then he immediately
followed it up with okay well then can
we just watch a movie
now in that case I knowingly allowed
myself to be suckered by the strategy
and I let them watch a movie but on a
cultural level in the in the battle with
the left
we cannot be so easily duped by these
kinds of Tricks just because non-binary
is arguably a little weirder weirder
than trans that doesn't make trans
legitimate or any closer to legitimate
than it was before
celebrating Jeffree Star at this point
it's like if somebody was beating you
over the head with a baseball bat and
then Jeffree Star ran in and said no
don't beat him over the head with a
baseball bat just stomp on his face with
your boot instead here I'll help
now it's true that getting stomped is
probably a little better than being
bludgeoned with a bat but does that
automatically make the person stomping
on your face an ally
would you applaud this person as they
kick you in the skull and say wow this
guy's great we should invite him to CPAC
no he's still your enemy he's still
trying to kill you just perhaps in a
slightly less efficient manner
see the curse of the big tent
conservatism approach is that now our
tent is filled with people who are
directly trying to undermine our cause a
big tent doesn't do a lot of good when
you're inviting people under it who will
just try to rip it down and leave all of
us standing in the rain which is what's
happening
one last point on all this
star says that we need someone who looks
like him to say the things that he says
because if we say it that is if normal
people who aren't cross-dressing circus
performers say it then we will be called
bigots and transphobes well except this
logic is refuted by his follow-up video
in which he defends himself against
accusations of bigotry and transphobia
so it turns out that tokenism is not
actually an effective strategy here we
cannot insulate ourselves from criticism
by putting our arguments into the mouths
of people who fall into identity
categories that the left usually
celebrates
okay I don't know how conservatives keep
thinking this strategy will work it
never has it never will
doesn't work
like can you give me an example of
someone who's in one of these identity
groups and they make it conservative
well not even conservative they make a
slightly less less left-wing argument
and the left goes well you know normally
I disagree with that but this person is
an identity group that we support so I
think we'll take into consideration has
that ever happened is there one example
of that working
no it doesn't because the left values
ideological Conformity over all else
their vision of diversity is one in
which people of all Races ethnicities
sexual orientations except white males
and made-up genders come together
to march in lockstep and speak in unison
anybody who misses a beat or forgets a
line or tries to improvise will be cast
out is not only a bigot but a traitor as
well as it turns out the people from
protected classes who disagree with the
left
are not given softer treatment or a
better chance at a fair hearing if
anything they're shouted down although
louder and hated all the more
because on top of uh of saying the
things that the left hates there's also
the element of betrayal
because the left says well you're
supposed to belong to us because of your
identity
that doesn't make them that doesn't make
the you know the heretic more credible
in the eyes of the left it just makes
them a heretic
just look at Jeffree Star he agrees with
the left on nearly everything
and he's living exactly the kind of
Lifestyle they promote but they still
Exile him for mildly criticizing one
small facet of gender ideology
well that doesn't make him our Ally or
our friend
but it does prove that this whole you
know you need people like me to make
this argument claim is moot
no we don't need people like him to make
the argument we don't need a
cross-dressing trans activist with neck
tattoos and copious amounts of makeup to
make the argument you know who we need
this goes back to the beginning of the
show we need normal people
normal people like you normal Common
Sense people who live normal lives and
dress and act like normal people we need
them to speak up and be advocates
because after all normalcy is what we're
trying to defend isn't it the best
defender of normalcy is a normal person
and not just one normal person but
Legions of them an army of normal people
demanding a return to sanity and Common
Sense and basic moral decency Jeffree
Star
is not ever going to be an effective
Champion for that cause
but you can be
and that is why Jeffree Star and his
conservative Defenders are today
canceled that'll do it for this portion
of the shows move over to the members
block if you're not a member yet you can
become a member by using Code wallsha
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
hope to see you over there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]